he is and now phasing jordan popper east
in blitz tiebreak jordan chose to start
with the white pieces here we go here we
go it's an italian game so it's the best
of two blitz games each player will have
one white one black and they only start
with five minutes on the clock gaining
three seconds after every move so it's
gonna quicken up sharpen up and okay a
quick trade of pawns in the center of
the board this is the most trendy
variation now of the italian game
um this one surely has been studied by
both players now either white's pawn on
the side of the board will push up two
squares the a pawn or white will
centralize the white rook those are the
two main moves here
okay what is shaq gonna do
oh sorry jordan gonna do okay he brings
out his knight also a decent move shaq
with black
is gonna maybe bring out his bishop move
the black knight from the center this
one is still very well known in this
type of position
who is the best in blitz
among these two
big question they're both good we saw
jordan knock out a niche and beat anish
in the blitz thai breaks shaq is very
good at blitz in general but i think he
prefers over the board to online blitz
um so maybe jordan a bit better with the
mouse but shuck very very good chakura
also beat anish in this tie breaks
actually true that's true uh also it was
i have to say both um both victories
over anish were kind of due to anish's
mistakes yeah uh you know he had great
positions in both matches and it just
seemed like an unfortunate series of
events that happened and
yeah sadly he lost the matches and uh
well shakur are doing some of my
favorite things taking space by pushing
pawns
yeah those pawn pushers are very very
committal they do leave some weaknesses
behind but they did get rid of white's
knight in the center white tonight in
the center went to trade itself off for
a bishop so it's still level pawns level
pieces on the board but black has this
really nice pawn center
white as compensation has the bishop
pair and we see white trying to break
open the position for his bishops
this could be a bit of a battle of
theory as well i mean this very active
move from white can be quite dangerous
if the queen can fly out next move
threatening checkmate that's something
to think about uh black has beautiful
center with those pawns but a little bit
loose at the moment somewhat and uh two
bishops for uh for jordan as well but
again this must be well-known stuff yeah
um at least until the last couple of
moves i had seen the position before i'm
not sure i've seen this exact position
um i'm definitely expecting uh that
knight to be kicked out from blacks half
of the board okay first shaq just
solidifies the black pawn center
and as you mentioned simon white's queen
can fly out to team up with her knight
batman and robin there
i was thinking actually during the break
maybe we should name uh
end games when you have a bishop and a
rook b and r batman and robin oh yes
queen of knights we need another
nickname
sharp stuff david after a long day yeah
well we did get some suggestions on
twitter some of them like very obvious
tom and jerry
oh how could we not think of that one uh
peanut butter and uh
jelly
yeah never tried it yeah that's an
american thing very american i don't
think i've ever had it actually really i
have is it is it good yeah it's okay i
do know that in england as well
very naughty you guys like to have chips
on your toast
chip putty
it's a chip butty chips and bread well
chips and gravy chips and curry sauce
fish and chips fish and cheese
and also call the police
in the meantime um like we do see the
center clarify itself with shakarya
taking space and i have to say i really
like his position i really like what
he's done uh to me he should be just
moving his knight out of the way and
just rerouting it to the right side of
the board so that it can advance or help
advance those pawns come forward so
black has two knights of anchor you want
to move them both i get i guess ideally
towards this right half of the board
because that's where the action will
happen uh meanwhile we should mention
the weird placement of white's knight
that will rectify itself white tonight
will recentralize uh later on and okay
one of the ideas ivanka mentioned has
happened
black stepping back with the knight
slowly kind of rerouting it towards the
right half of the board and offering a
bishop trade no bishop trade though from
jordan the light squared bishops are
essential to white's uh future plans so
okay the white bishop stepping back
losing time though jarv this is the
ideal attacking position for him and
he's an attacking player as black i mean
if he can ever move the pawn the the
freddie pawn the f pawn uh two squares
forwards then that'll be a crushing
attack but this is the pawn he really
wants to move but he just can't move it
at the moment uh so he needs to he needs
to repair as you say bring some pieces
around to support uh maybe an avalanche
of pawns here
but i think jordan's got things under
control he does control
lots of those squares on the king side
which are going to be dangerous
yeah and uh meanwhile ma'am durov just
ticking under three minutes
he's not been playing too quickly so far
i'm not sure he's adapted to the pace
jordan at three and a half minutes
still not great pace both players may be
struggling to adapt to the blitz
after the rapid section and okay manager
of taking a good decision blocking the
advance of white's pawns on this left
side
now play will switch to the other flank
and there we go jordan is the one trying
to open things up on this flank
double-edged that's where white's king
sits he's pushing pawns in front of his
own king
that could backfire but then again he
does have the bishops and if he can open
up lines open up diagonals then white's
bishops become strong and okay porn
trade will we see a rook trade as well
now on this open f line the rooks are
staring at each other yeah it does feel
like if you do trade off rooks that
maybe
it will be easier for chakrillar to play
and instead jordan
improves the placing of his knight
because there was a direct threat of
bishop takes night on the board
um now as the question is to take or not
to take
yeah and romeo and juliet
i love it
randomly people are just randomly
getting them
oh yeah oh my goodness me
we are so bad
okay knight takes night on the board
and uh presumably i will probably play
bishop takes knight just to keep the
tension still
it's a lovely bishop that dark square
bishop and i'm starting to look at
white's position and think yeah this is
this is going white's wave white can get
the queen over to the king side maybe we
could possibly just show that with
arrows coming e1 to g3 or or somewhere
like that that just it's just white's
dark square bishop fantastic piece let's
quickly show the simon as the clocks
tick down white wants to relocate the
queen potentially bringing the queen
over planting it in front of the king
and attacking but this hasn't happened
white instead pushing a pawn maybe
trying to play in the center um yeah
let's go back to the players i like this
queen maneuver bring the queen over if
jordan finds it he's got very good
chances to win this game
black's knight going back it's all about
this queen maneuver right now going for
the black king using this point and
teaming up with the bishop yeah lots of
arrows there but it's all about
utilizing this white queen maybe the
other bishop can come into the game as
well but he's moved his queen another
way which also makes sense connecting
the rooks there just doubling up the
rooks but i think white has a very
sizable advantage here because white
also has the brakes here white has this
pawn breaker you mentioned to try attack
the center white can move his bishop in
at the right time and all of his pieces
are on the king's side i don't really
like black's pieces especially black's
bishop look at the bishop it just looks
like an extra pawn at the moment and the
pawn chain is a big pawn not a bishop
yeah and uh okay white rooks are coming
in now
this is looking very good all of white's
pieces they protect each other this is
what we always talk about when we talk
about coordination combining the pieces
utilizing them as a team uh yeah and if
you can use them as one unit they are
great together and there we go white
queen blockades black's best porn the
most dangerous black porn queens aren't
great blockaders but it's good enough
for now and jordan
taking control manager
taking full control and now all that's
needed is that the light square bishop
just comes out
and uh suddenly
the bishop power just gonna start
looking at black's king it's it's very
very unpleasant also there's queen g3
and you can move the bishop into into
the position so i think that's what i
expect now just h3 or something yeah and
he's played it going for your idea
ivanka the light square bishop would
love to join in this game now
yeah black's queen staring down at the
white king but i was about to say the
white king can just shift onto a dart
square white has full control of the
dark squares this is why bishop pairs
together are so good black's minor
pieces just
can't get in the game they can't have
any influence white's bishop's dancing
into the position now going after
targets black's pawn on the side of the
board attacked by that white bishop so
many problems here because even if black
tries to exchange off all the pieces
pretty much he's going to be left
playing against the two bishops so you
can't the bishops you can't relieve the
pressure by making exchanges here and
black's pawns are being attacked by that
dark square bishop of jordans and could
even be a pawn dropping any second now
yeah how does mamadou keep the position
together the black knight kind of under
threat by this last bishop move by white
but just look at white's two bishops
they control every important square in
the center of the board
and uh yeah
it's just so hard to even find a move
manager of offering a rook trade here
but that surely won't help at all you
can trade rooks and maybe even get
greedy grabs and pawns he has there we
go he has and i don't think bishop takes
porn works here because there's a nasty
tactic um okay because the bishop can
always attack the knight could this be
two pawns he's dropping now this is
really bad yeah
really bad for mama jarov he's trying to
get rid of one of white's bishops at any
cost but it's a high cost giving up two
pawns potentially white is one porn up
for now but white's bishop can go and
grab a pawn on the edge of the board as
well two pawn advantage should be game
over white's king pretty safe as well
for now also white can even go on the
counter attack with the queen and he has
that and he has played that move he's
trying to keep it very simple and keep
the pressure up throttling the black
knight yep yeah and wow okay major of
taking bishops allowing his knight to
drop off we saw all of the minor pieces
disappear but jordan he has a few more
pawns this is brave though because
suddenly queen end games they're tricky
lots of checks in the position white
starts first though with the tracks and
it's also whoever has the past pawn
that's further advanced and at least
mama jaroff has that one uh pawn in the
middle of the board it's only three
squares away from queening so he can try
to combine that with some queen checks
to get some chances here yeah i think
jordan is banking on the fact that uh
his king can easily catch that pawn but
uh it's a good tactic tactic at the
minute just to kind of repeat moves just
to get some extra time on the clock you
have the moves flying onto the board
jordan actually repeated very quickly we
barely even saw it uh but there we go
another set of checks and all of black's
pawns are dropping white is two pawns up
now and it's not just that look at why
it's pawn in the middle of the board
it's free to run
and uh this one it's almost game over
surely now mamajora can't save this game
look at the clock times two minutes for
jordan as well plenty of time all he
needs to do is push his extra pawn in
the middle yeah yeah and uh it's easy
very easy to guard his king that's a
mamajara's only hope to give a perpetual
check can he do it jordan will say no
absolutely not
yeah and here comes the pawn two squares
no checks winning the game
two squares will we see a queen or will
uh they gave me over before
the game will be over before that i
don't think they ever allow it do they
the end unfortunately in these ones but
uh okay at least black's got his queen
behind uh there's always some half
chances but it really is actually maybe
not even a half one percent chance here
i feel it's oh and a hundred on the bar
yeah i mean that means it's a clear win
for white white should make a new queen
with that far advanced pawn if he's
accurate as simon says there's only one
or two percent chance that this could go
wrong and that's if you forget the
safety of the white king uh if you're
careless
okay jordan just repeat oh okay not
repeating the position there i was gonna
say if you're careless and abandon the
white king it might backfire later on
here we go the white king is about to
walk out into the open surprising that's
surprising i thought he was gonna tuck
it in the corner just move it up one
square totally agree why is it gone this
way it's opening up opening up to checks
at least giving black that one chance
and the valuation bar definitely not at
100 anymore it's down to only plus two
for white should still be winning shakur
has to check on the right squares
white's king wants to wander over to the
left side of the board the white king
actually wants to walk towards its pawn
but look at the evaluation part it's
dropped completely
maybe it's a draw now with best play
white's queen is terribly placed oh and
he's
born as well
yeah jordan just
oh rubbing his brow there shaking his
head there's so many missed
opportunities by jordan today i mean i i
think this is still very close to
winning you just gotta find somewhere
for the king to go but can you find
anywhere for the key valuation bar says
no if the black queen checks now and
goes back you can't match up the board
because white actually has a risk of
losing now there are some traps where
you walk your king into a checkmate
okay majority of checks diagonally
that's supposed to be very good wisdom
in queen end games but
another piece of good wisdom put your
queen in the center of the board jordan
didn't do it look at the white queen she
can't block any checks because she's on
the wrong side of the king
and i mean the thing here is though
we've talked about the the position of
the king when you're defending and
black's king is kind of in an ideal
situation because uh it is uh it's
avoiding any checks here yeah there was
a nasty check uh trick in the position
he can do it again
so if white steps the king one square
forward that would be a dreadful move it
would be terrible mistake because the
queen would dash to the f6 square and be
checkmate and uh
the white king just can't escape the
checks i i think this coming into the
center was totally the wrong idea i mean
you have to go back towards the king
side here i feel and and tried to block
with the queen but i don't know how you
can ever achieve that with uh good
defense and this one percent well
it was it was a big one percent chance
wasn't it it's a massive one chance it
it looked over and now uh mama java's
just fighting yeah if jordan doesn't win
this game mama jaroff is a huge favorite
in the last round uh i mean jordan he
missed a huge opportunity to draw the
last game he should have won this game
and uh i mean still some small chances
if he can find a safe square for his
king but looks impossible no matter
where you go you get checked look at
white's queen as well stuck it can never
jump back and defend because the black
queen is eyeing up the white pawn but
now he's going the right way this is the
way that maybe he should have gone in
the first place can he go can he get it
out the way in time now i mean why not i
mean the king's gotta use it
yeah
he's just had a bit of fun walking
around the board losing a pawn in the
process but he's not going he's not
going that way though the evaluation bar
shot up for white meaning it's maybe
winning again
and we actually had this position
earlier but white still had a pawn on
the left side of the board so he's
basically just lost a pawn for nothing
and still can't find the win valuation
bar's going crazy isn't it i mean it's
it's all over the shop and now it's
going that way again so uh but we i mean
jordan's tried to move the king this way
i don't think it's going to work uh no
matter where it goes okay he's trying to
win this one
on the edge of the board though if i'm
expecting white to go one square left
now with his king
hide itself behind the black pawn so now
at least you've won the black pawn
but actually if you take it there's
nowhere to hide yeah the queen pick it's
an immediate draw yeah the queen will
just simply give a check one square
forward and has kind of got the king
shouldered in
so
not a good safety place for the king
that instead
yeah is this an easy draw now because i
think you can just keep two squares
away from the king wherever the king
goes if it goes to the right you check
it from two squares away the problem
white has i think it's mentioned is the
white queen uh the white queen is not
it's not controlling enough squares here
if it was in the middle of the board it
would control some of those checking
squares that black has but
it it's helping the pawn but nothing
else yeah i mean it's not in a position
to give any cross-checks it's something
that we saw in yesterday's game um
oh two days ago
yeah you saw an amazing really
instructive really classic queen end
game between magnus carson and pregnant
where magnus won by using the white
queen in the middle of the board jordan
clearly wasn't watching that game
clearly hasn't studied queen end games i
mean he's trying to i guess put the king
next to the queen now is that this is
the only chance i i can see uh but that
that also comes a little bit of risk
he's going back could it be a draw yeah
we've been at this almost this exact
position before i'm pretty sure we've
seen that position two times now jordan
has to be careful if he puts his king on
the wrong square the position will
repeat for a third time and game over
immediately with a draw
and jordan look at his face he's
devastated yeah it's so close yeah and
so far away i mean it's kind of a repeat
tale of what happened again he relaxes
one move too soon he's really trying to
draw this match he'll lose this match i
mean he's had so many chances i mean
you know you just feel that the way it's
going mamajara must be favorite in the
last game with the white pieces as well
no way out for this white king look how
the black queen is keeping the white
king in its box in the corner you can
try and run across the board now but
again you'll get mated
you know if you go if you go here you'll
get mated you have to yeah this is the
only way otherwise checkmate
and there we go a draw in the first
blitz game ewing with the white pieces
wasn't able to convert that to a win and
in five minutes blitz game number two
look at him
angry with himself